we slapped an experimental head rig on
his head and said now be the star of
this movie the actors behind the navi
and avatars dealt with long days limited
vision and heavily wired motion capture
suits there's a lot of work a lot of
body work and a lot of Behavioral work
that I had to do long before filming
started the casts were brought into the
studio for a long and tiresome Full Body
Casting experience in order to make
these life-sized models the actors had
to sit with restrictive plastic wrap all
over their face while layers of plaster
cast were applied all while unable to
see smell or breathe very well and this
was just the beginning of the process
while the cast had to suffer through the
arduous ordeal it was a major help to
the creative team who needed the molds
to create highly detailed scans to send
along to the designers that were then
able to create the incredible
transformation from Human to Navi or
Avatar all while keeping each character
visually comparable to the actor playing
them the idea that I had clung to for a
long time was this idea of mounting a
camera directly to the actor's head
those full body casts came in handy when
it came time to make specially fitted
head rigs that the actors had to wear
throughout their entire performance so
we wind up with a tight fitting carbon
fiber helmet this headgear was heavy
duty a kind of cross between a skull cap
and a helmet that were made to fit like
skin on the actor's heads so they could
keep all the mocap markers steady these
caps weren't easy to wear since they had
all sorts of gear attached like wires
cat-like ears and even motion capture
ready hair not to mention the carbon
fiber arm with a tiny but powerful
camera on the end of it that reached
around to the front of the actor's face
while the addition of the camera was
necessary to capture the nuances of the
performers facial movements and
expressions it could make actually
performing challenging as a camera in
front of the face could obstruct views
and get in the performer's way
fortunately the actors managed to Brave
through and performed with no bounds the
result is pretty incredible 100
committed performances
the mocap suits used in Avatar truly
became like second skins for the actor
though they weren't always the most
comfortable skins there is nothing
natural feeling about a full body
form-fitting suit kitted up with wires
and heavy battery packs you've got a
bunch of markers on the actor's body
that are being picked up by hundreds of
cameras very very little time was spent
in the makeup chair
fly to the face were dots for the
and the Wardrobe Department was really
just the motion capture suit Department
with the distraction of all these
technical looking suits cameras and
wires everywhere an actor turned the one
thing they could keep a clear focus on
was each other's eyes since those were
never covered having that connection
amidst all the technology was key and a
definite motivator to help the actors
through when filming felt tough on top
of the actress's photograph then we
would turn her into a Navi on top of the
body casts the team decided to obtain as
much visual reference as they could of
each cast member in the development
process each of the actors were brought
in for a special photo shoot one that
involved a giant sphere filled with
large bright lights and multiple cameras
surrounding inside the sphere the actors
were Troopers through the process to
help the designers gather as much detail
about their physicality and facial
details the photo shoots didn't end in
the sphere though an incredible amount
of photos were taken while the actors
performed very various activities
including archery and wacky facial
expressions as Zoe Saldana and Sam
Worthington found themselves running
through the jungles of Hawaii they
definitely experienced the elements
maybe a bit too intensely for their
liking I was I was naked
for three days in Hawaii since James
Cameron wanted the actors to experience
these filming experiments as their
characters he had them in the actual
clothing their characters would wear and
that didn't consist of much did a couple
of scenes we ran around in Lauren cloth
the fact caught the actors by surprise
as it never really occurred to them just
how minimal their actual costumes were
not an easy experience but we have a
feeling Saldana and Worthington were
very close after enduring that together
if you haven't gathered by now the
preparation to bring Avatar to the
screen was long and intense but it did
include a trip to Hawaii to explore and
film in Kauai amongst the mountains and
through the jungles an incredible
experience but this wasn't a vacation
this was work which meant everyone had
to deal with the very real rainforest
elements just as their characters would
have had to the performers were even set
up with costume details like their tails
and their characters accessories while
Saldana got to it's the motion capture
suit for this she did need to wear what
her character would have and if you've
seen Avatar you know it's not very much
this became especially tough on the days
when the weather wasn't so great and the
performers were facing all the elements
[Music]
let's go
every actor had to go through a very
intense training regimen before they
could even begin filming Sam Worthington
went through extensive boxing and
military training even getting the
chance to work with a former Marine who
just happened to be James Cameron's
brother John David Cameron Worthington
had to be confident enough in his
training to be able to give a full
performance while restricted by the
motion capture suit and helmet and he
definitely delivered Zoe Saldana pretty
much became an expert at performing
highly demanding physical activities
while wearing her full body performance
suit long hair on the cap included the
actress had to learn how to shoot a bow
and arrow both the human way and the
navi way left-handed and with their
hands reversed while this was
Supernatural for the navi it was far
from simple for the performers and the
fact that they were wearing their full
motion capture suits and headgear only
added a layer of difficulty and
discomfort the training was rigorous two
Olympic team trainers were there to whip
the cast into shape and from what we see
in the movie they didn't disappoint I
had to take everything I learned in
training and applied to my first day Las
Alonso AKA sute trained so much that he
was able to ride a horse with speed and
jump off all while looking graceful this
was vital since he really was riding a
horse when filming and while in his wire
and battery pack covered suit these
Feats weren't just difficult but
dangerous as well wearing the headgear
meant the performer's view could be
obstructed by the camera in front which
is the last thing a person would want
riding a horse the high-tech suits also
spent some time climbing up a model
built in the studio to represent the
Beanstalk the performers were attached
to wires with heavy sandbags at the ends
enabling the actors to speedily scale
their way up translating to the
animalistic otherworldly Movement we see
on screen as for the scenes when the
characters are soaring through the air
when you see them flying these things
they're working hard are we surprised
the day after filming these rigorous
scenes was always a tough one and let
the actors physically exhausted not to
mention overwhelmed by their second skin
suits as for the large group scenes
Terry notary was brought in to lead the
actors through movement workshops and
training a rigorous process that was key
for the success of the film hours were
spent becoming fluent in the navi
physicalities so they could all suit up
and perform massive dances like this
just seeing all the tech the performers
had to wear is overwhelming Avatar is a
feast for the eyes and truly a Triumph
for filmmaking Shane was like come on
Nick Jerry suck it I'm like right right
okay Zoe leave this is a jungle no TV no
Blackberry the Avatar movies might be
all CGI but these actors perform every
single stunt wear elaborate costumes and
work with professional trainers to make
sure they can run jump fight and even
hold their breath for over seven minutes
we've got a lot to talk about here
that's great
take it easy don't get ahead of yourself
okay okay number one director James
Cameron always goes for authenticity
even if it's incredibly dangerous to
shoot it wasn't enough for the actors to
voice CGI characters that were
underwater they actually had to be able
to do it themselves Kate Winslet managed
to hold her breath for 7 minutes and 14
seconds it was brilliant and I was very
proud of myself and I'll probably never
be able to do it again that came at the
end of four weeks worth of quite intense
training most challenging for me was to
physically play a 14 year old girl
number two she really went through the
ringer for this film being a 72 year old
actor didn't hold her back from doing
the same rigorous training as every
other actor in this film she and the
rest of her castmates had to unlearn a
lot of normal human behaviors while
swimming underwater for long periods of
time sometimes their shoots would have
them submerged in water for over 12
hours learning how to not squint or
clamp their mouth shut both natural
react actions when you're submerged
during take after take in a gigantic
water tank she had to have the
professional diver speed her back to the
surface for air just in case she wasn't
able to make it up fast enough
number three imagine being held down
underwater with weights around your
waist not only did the actors have to be
trained on holding their breath but they
also had to make sure they stayed
submerged that's where the weights come
into play Sam Worthington really
struggled with filming underwater mostly
due to his own fear it's the hardest
thing I've ever had to do you're dealing
with the restrictions of free diving the
constraints of motion capture underwater
and you're trying to keep an emotional
Journey going while you're innately
struggling with the fear of dying
do emotion underwater without you know
how do you not look like a blowfish
number four we know the actors pretty
much do it all okay
action every major stunt that you see on
camera was performed by the actors
themselves they had to run they had to
leave they had to fight they had to do
all the things that you see them doing
in the film considering that the actors
were also clad in painful CGI suits and
head rigs they definitely left the shoot
every day incredibly sore just look at
these massive leaps Zoe Saldana had to
do one of the things that I'm always
going to take with me is the fact that I
was a part of a revolutionary experience
in Hollywood number five just another
part of the brutal physical training the
actors had to go through when you hold a
bow you have to kind of like you know
hold it this way but the navi hold it
that way the rigorous hours of training
in such an odd way left the actors hands
and arms super cramped and sore
afterward that was one of the biggest
things we had to work with for her it's
how to shoot this bow and arrow another
dangerous aspect besides just generally
dealing with weapons was you need to
have perfect Aim so you don't hit
something you're not supposed to luckily
for Zoe Saldana I have really good aim
but her downfall after so many hours of
practices I can only shoot like a navi I
cannot do archery like a human go figure
number six yes they got to ride actual
horses on set but it wasn't easy they
had to do tons of training in order to
be able to ride bareback and manage the
horses properly also because the
headgear they were wearing they didn't
always have a perfect peripheral view
not great when you're riding a live
animal we also can't forget about Sam
worthington's stunt where he takes a
hard fall off his horse
ouch that definitely had to hurt
number seven there's a lot of
hand-to-hand combat in these movies this
type of martial arts the actors had to
learn was called wushu which is a very
graceful form of martial arts that I I
grew up to like after I trained the
actors had to do months of intense
training pushing through all the aches
and pains that came with the learning of
the new physical skill number eight
anytime an actual weapon is on set
always creates an element of danger
luckily for the cast They had military
trainers to help prepare them to work
with their weapon of choice they want
you to kind of be proficient with
weaponry and stuff like that because
regarding the rain Sam Worthington had
to be super prepped in his military
training as he had to do all of the
movements in the bulky motion capture
suit and helmet number nine let's talk
about the way navis move we have to go
through not just climbing rocks but also
how to climb through the vines Iran Choi
had some major stunts to perform jump
from space to space while also staying
true to the navi movement he might be a
hunter or he'll be a soldier they had
him step in for several characters
because he was one of the few to be able
to hit all of the dangerous choreography
in such a Flawless manner he was even
one of the amp suits that was being
developed Sam Worthington had his own
style of movements he and James Cameron
based on his ability to serve when I
started talking about flying the
Banshees and the Leon optrics like a
like a board sport like this kind of
athletic thing he was able to get into
it in a way that felt natural to him
while still maintain his Navi movement
which brings us to our next point
number 10. a lot of prep went into
creating the Navy's fighting style we
had to design not just other stunts but
also the movements that would be
associated with the Navies they only had
a month and a half to train the actors
so they had a lot to squeeze in they had
to design fight scenes specifically for
those movements to shine through any
choreographed scene that came off too
human had to be reworked which naturally
required a lot of takes and a lot of
patience it's a lot more difficult than
I would have thought we had to
constantly be on them every day about
how they were fighting number 11 even
getting into character is dangerous
every actor had to go through the Life
cast process which they used to design
the characters basically they had to
wear restrictive plastic all over their
face while another layer of plaster was
poured over them going through this made
it extremely difficult to hear see smell
and even breathe though a vigorous
process it was highly necessary as those
designs get scanned into computer files
to get made into what we eventually see
on screen
number 12 things got really method for a
few days we knew we were doing that
James Cameron wanted to prepare his
actors for shooting in an entirely CGI
world because we knew that ultimately we
were going to wind up in a fully CG
rainforest with full ECG characters and
it had to look real by taking them to
the rainforest for reference needless to
say it definitely wasn't the most
comfortable or safe experience for the
crew I took the actors on what I called
a sense memory Odyssey we went to Kauai
we lived in the rainforest for a few
days we cooked an underground fire pits
we drank water from the leaves he wanted
them to bring those experiences back to
the set the way they placed their hands
and feet when walking up a steep section
The Sounds the smells and everything in
between that could be utilized for the
world of Avatar Zoe Saldana said that
those were the most physically demanding
days of her life just digging and
climbing and muddy and especially
because she had to wear her actual
costume we're videotaping and we're
going through the inside of this jungle
cap ready and actually
if you're listening to this on your
phone you might want to hide it before
James Cameron sees bad things happen to
those on their phone but if you are
brave enough we're looking at all the
coolest secrets from the making of
Avatar number one did you realize
Sigourney Weaver didn't just play a
younger character in the way of water
it's true she already technically was
playing a younger character in the first
movie perhaps you never noticed this
little detail but her Avatar had been
around for 18 years so it looks 18 years
younger than Sigourney or even her human
character Grace Grace
well who'd you expect numbnuts creating
her Avatar was the toughest because her
features did not translate well to the
Avatar design and so the artists tasked
with making her design brought in
pictures of her from the movie Alien
number two let's start at the end the
end that never was that is the original
ending of Avatar was going to see a
pregnant natiri we are kind of glad they
didn't end it the cliche way not gonna
lie the movie was already leaning on a
ton of them ones that had already gone
out of style in the 90s so it's for the
best the forest will heal
hearts of the people the people number
three he's coming supposedly if your
cell phone went off James Cameron would
nail gun them to a wall he did that with
like 20 apparently right above the exit
sign let that be a reminder to everyone
to turn it off in theaters when the way
of water comes out number four where do
you even begin when forming a language
our guess is the little words like the
where's
an entire language was created for the
navi from scratch by linguist Dr Paul R
frommer what were we going to establish
and then how was everyone else going to
meet that Criterion he was hired to
develop a language that would be easy
for actors to pronounce that didn't
resemble any existing language he
created about 1 000 words
Zoe Saldana was in charge of creating
the accent for the navi in English since
she had to speak it the most Sam
Worthington said it was easier for him
an Australian to master the navi
language than the American accent these
guys were just going off number five a
wide range of training was necessary to
get the actors militarized and then
acclimated to Nature Sam Worthington who
plays Jake actually had to do military
boot camp to bring him closer to his
character he had to learn to use
multiple different weapons so someone
came down and showed him what it's like
to hold a gun and all the other things
that would be associated with being a
while Zoe had to move completely
unhumanlike right down to working with
her bow with her elbow bent backwards so
we wanted them to have more of a animal
kind of a movement number six where did
Jurassic Park rip off all its Dino
noises from the real thing but there is
a banshee Lane which makes all kinds of
different sounds and those sounds mean
different things most of the sounds the
animals make on Pandora are recycled
noises from the Jurassic Park franchise
while the yipping and cackling sounds
made by the Viper wolves were real
spotted hyena calls
number seven they could have bummed a
smoke off of literally anybody why rely
on Tech just like almost everything else
in this movie Grace Augustine's
cigarette is CGI honestly we didn't see
that one coming number eight not that
kind of cast Jake's atrophied legs were
Prosthetics cast from the legs of a
paraplegic man with roughly the same
bone structure as Sam Sam worthington's
real legs were tucked into the
wheelchair and digitally removed in
post-production number nine we feel the
navi should also have six limbs all the
Pandora animals have six limbs it wasn't
that simple to just add two extra legs
to an earth horse though they had to
reimagine the anatomy of the characters
too they all moved like ants their front
four legs moved together but the back
two were separate the multiple breathing
orifices were inspired by air intakes on
the sides of sports cars we guess you
can get your inspiration from anywhere
what's the metaphor what are we trying
to say to the audience with every bone
and sinew that we put into to this
creature number 10. make them different
but not so different that they aren't
sexy James Cameron took inspiration for
the navi from his mother who had a dream
about a tall blue woman he drew a
picture of it way back in high school
too in designing natiri one of the
challenges was making her look alien but
also human enough that Jake's attraction
to her isn't super off-putting they went
through a ton of designs I wanted people
to say I want to be one of them number
11. how many movies can you think of
really pushed advancements as much as
Avatar none Avatar paved the way for
Tekken movies like we know it today the
navi actors had cameras attached to
helmets to capture intimate facial
performances they were able to see
simple renderings of the CGI World while
filming the actual facial capture is too
complex to map onto these characters
this movie was also the first to film
using a 3D camera number 12. when
writers write often they include a
character with a personality similar to
their own for James Cameron that was Dr
Grace Augustine Sigourney said teased
him because to me I'm playing Jim
Cameron in the movie as this kind of
brilliant approach driven idealistic
perfectionist but that same somebody has
a great heart underneath so I have to
say I was always kind of channeling him
number 13. do you think the world was
ready to handle something new how do you
create music for a world that doesn't
exist the music in Avatar was a new
invention meant to not be linked in any
way to any culture Homer noted I
couldn't go off into some weird world
and present a whole new scale system or
a whole new theme system I had to try to
glue everything together no matter how
dense it is on the screen or how alien
it might be there is a thread in the
music that keeps it grounded for the
audience so they know what is going on
and how to feel number 14. one day Sam
Worthington will release a book about
his experience Sam was living in his car
at the time of his audition the person
who called him in for the audition told
him nothing about the director or the
script he was disappointed at first
thinking it was another waste of time
Matt Damon and Jake Gyllenhaal were
actually the Studio's first choices to
play Jake but James Cameron wanted to
cast the relatively unknown Sam I just
wanted to say thank you yeah thank you
number 15. Avatar is pretty ancient at
this point James Cameron promised not to
take his pay as director if Avatar
flopped this was just one on reassurance
20th Century Fox had that they wouldn't
lose all their money he originally
planned to have the film completed for
release in 1999 but the technology was
just not Advanced enough to tackle the
project in a way that was financially
reasonable while a lot of people say
Avatar is just Disney's Pocahontas that
isn't the full story James had been
developing Avatar since as far back as
the 60s he smooshed four of his scripts
together and even some early concept art
from high school the first script being
xenogenesis about scientists who try to
find a new planet to live on the second
Chrysalis was about a man in a
wheelchair who has all of his sensory
inputs removed so he can journey through
his own mind the third mother was about
a company who sets up Minds on other
planets the rest of the elements of the
story went to his movie Alien and the
last one wind Warriors was basically the
plot of Avatar except set on Earth in
order to develop a fully realized world
it's easy to see why you need a team of
Highly skilled and super knowledgeable
people to develop single aspects imagine
trying to come up with the language
music culture creatures and Technology
to capture it all yourself it's an
impossible task unless you've got your
master's degree in literally everything
do you have those million dollar ideas
that are just so big you don't know
where to start let us know in the
comments and thanks for hanging out with
us here at the things
[Music]